hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com i've been working as a
professional trainer for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now i'm doing youtube videos
guys
because i want to pass the knowledge and
i want to show you guys
how i do my analysis and what tools i
use so if you want to know about all the
stuff
you are in the right place so uh today i
want to keep talking about
uh the bubble that is for me coming as i
showed you guys on the video on the s p
500
i did a few days ago and i want to
analyze the nasdaq
and show you guys what kind of
indicators you can use to see if we're
in a bubble or not
let's get into it
[Music]
so uh this is the nasdaq on the uh
weekly time frame
so we have data since 1986 guys uh
so here we had a strong move up we have
actually here the dot com bubble so
we're gonna
use this uh data to actually see what we
can have
and you can see that we had a linear
move for uh
nine years from 89 to 97
and then we broke this resistance level
that was a trend line
we retested it look guys
we broke it we retested it we break it
again we test and you know this whole
move becomes exponential and here we
have the bubble all right so the bubble
really starts for me here
right and then it takes 400 percent
so this is the first sign you can use
when you have a very
strong bullish trend with a trend line
like this
that makes resistance once this
resistance
is broken and you can see that it's
acting as support
as we had here guys i just do the same
thing you know
and we have the breakout here re-tested
we go higher we test again we go higher
so i think we
we might retest it one more time around
12 000
within like a few months and this is
going to be the last chance to buy guys
if you are short it would be the last
chance to actually cut your position
because what is going to follow guys
might be the same kind of stuff all
right so if i just do a visual
drawing that is actually to me quite
efficient you know
a bubble you know this is a bubble guys
all right so if we're having a bubble
we're gonna have something like this so
the nasdaq might go to
45 000 guys yes this is a serious target
45 000
would be a level that we might see if
the market
uh enters a bubble actually the case is
that we broke this trend line you know
during the covet crisis i did as i said
a video on the s p 500
and i will show you that uh this fifth
wave is not finished
uh because this is actually a
four that is broken on the upside and
the fifth wave is actually coming
and it's it might go to something like
7000 you know same thing it's just
visual
if i use fibs uh i have you know a level
of 7 000 so you know 5
300 would be a normal level but if we're
on a bubble it would be seven
thousand you know something like this so
go check it out guys this was my video
that i did yesterday
so for now what we can say is that we
are not in a bubble but
we are at the beginning of it now guys i
want to do something very interesting so
you can do the same guys uh
what you can follow to see if the bubble
starts
so the first thing that i've spotted is
the old market guys so the old market is
in a corrective phase
during bubbles what is happening let's
have a look so the bubble really started
in 1999
and as you can see guys in 1999 the old
market
so it's here all right jenna so it's
somewhere here
from 2000 so it's here it took
uh 300 guys
you know the old market took 300 percent
during
internet bubble so right now we have a
nice
resistance on the old market that is
actually at 62.
so if we having this bubble this is the
first thing you need to look at
for now we having the breakout on the
equity market we don't have it on the
old market
so if i see here a breakout coming then
you know i would know that my scenario
is actually
making sense for now if the oil market
is correcting
then probably the equity market is going
to correct as well so this is a very
nice thing to follow and here i expect
something like this
like i said i think that we're in a
bubble but guys my view can change
depending on what is happening if i see
the oil doing something like this
then i won't say we're in a bubble
anymore you know i would say all right
now the market is correcting
but if i see something like this
this is different if i see that guys
this is confirming my scenario that we
are in a bubble
so follow the oil and pay attention to
the 62 level we are expecting a breakout
and a retest
and if you have this it makes more sense
then
another thing what is the gold during a
bubble
the gold market basically didn't do much
it was here it went here
and this was the bubble burst okay so
the the gold market
is not very interesting to tell us if we
are on a bubble or not
what is the dollar doing if we're on a
bubble guys in 1999
the dollar was actually here going
higher guys
going higher from here
to here so the dollar to took 28
during the bubble so i know it's it was
not the same monetary policies i know we
cannot compare
you know things like this but this is
just one more indicator that i put
in my list that i keep an eye on all
right i know that
if we are in the bubble mode it means
that uh
probably the oil is gonna uh rally and
the
uh dxy is gonna rally what do i have
here
as i said guys i did videos on this as
well
i was seeing here a very strong support
that hold for now
and i was seeing this two wedge
descending wedge patterns
and right now i can see that we have
here something that looks like a
breakout
so if the dollar starts to increase
sharply
you know this is going to give me
another indication that my bubble
scenario
that is you know that my last one year
or two years is
uh actually happening and one more
stuff to watch guys what were the ten
years rates doing
during the bubble here guys it was at
it was at four and it went to
670 so around 60 and right now what do
we have guys we have this
rally on the 10-year you probably
followed this you know this is what
created actually the uh sell-off that we
had last week
is because the bond when the bond market
went higher the rate sorry went higher
and you have some momentum hedge funds
like ctas
that just if the rates are going higher
they're gonna
buy more rates sell more bonds and so
here
as you can see we have a lot of room
for the bond market to go higher i can
see here we have you know the
rate market that is just you know
shifting lower
but what is happening here is that we
have this strong rebound and here
we broke actually uh the 120 level
quite well so maybe we're gonna retest
it and then we have a lot of room
for this market to go higher in the
coming year so
and it's it's exciting exactly exactly
what happened in 2000
so if this market is going higher we're
going to have the rates going higher
just as they did
in uh 1999 the oil market to monitor
guys that
might go higher as well as it did in
1999
and the dxy that might go higher as it
did in 1999
we have all the you know different
indicators that point
in the same direction i mean not for now
for the oil but
i think it's gonna come we're gonna have
this breakout and
we have a strong market volatility you
know the vix is at
24. where was it in 1999
same levels guys it was here right
around 24. so we have
everything that is similar to this and
we have this huge money printing
with this misallocation of of this money
that once again is not going to the real
economy but to the uh
asset to the equity and the bond market
and we have all this crazy bullishness
from the new investors that are hungry
for easy money
and that you know are buying gamestop by
buying amc
uh are buying the wheat stocks and this
is
actually another sign so to me we have
all the signs
that this bubble is coming but once
again
look how is a bubble looking it looks
like this
right now it's linear so the bubble has
not come yet
so i expect crazy moves in the coming
year two years
maybe 100 to 100 percent but once again
i'm gonna keep an eye on all my
indicators
and see if yes or not uh they confirm
my scenario all right guys so that's it
for me i hope you enjoyed this video i
hope you know
uh i'm an age to explain to you how i
use the different
securities together how they are related
uh to actually build up a strong
view and if you did please don't forget
to click the like subscribe
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show
i see you guys